foreign
[Music]
it's time to say something that I've
been looking forward to for many many
years welcome to City skylines 2.
Paradox interactive has been kind enough
to grant me and many other content
creators early access to the game so we
can make some videos streams and whatnot
to show off what the game is all about
and during the next few months there
will be some other releases as well so
stay tuned for that but for now I just
want to use this opportunity to mess
around with the game a little bit and
try some ideas because honestly I know
there's going to be a lot of content out
there very quickly now to show you what
the game is all about and go through all
of the features and I don't think I'm
really best suited to add to that
conversation I just want to do something
that I find fun and see whatever it
turns into and after a bit of messing
around with the game once I got my hands
on it I was figuring out what I could do
for a little bit I was actually thinking
of making a Dutch City but honestly
that's just way too hard with the Assets
in the game it's nearly impossible but I
did notice that we have a bunch of row
houses we also have some nice detached
houses that look quite nice and all
together I think this game is already
pretty well suited to make an English
town and landscape and so that's what
I'm going to do here unfortunately we
don't have access to Hedges at least not
that I know of yet but still I think
with the road system the trees and the
buildings that we have in the game it's
very doable to do a small rural English
town with the surrounding Countryside
and I think it's a very typical look as
well that's really fun to work on too
now first thoughts about the game
because I do think it's uh good to also
share those the road system is
absolutely amazing and if you've already
spent your time lately looking forward
to this game and checking all of the
videos that Paradox has been releasing
about it you've probably already noticed
this but the road system is so much
better than City skylines too it's
really like they or a city Skylanders
one it's really like they took all of
the feedback that people had about the
road system in the first game and
decided to add everything that the
community was asking for and I think one
of the things that makes it so much
better is just that it's so easy to use
in the first game you were always kind
of fighting with it getting a roads that
you couldn't place and trying to hook up
and snap things together and it just
didn't work very well and in this game
the road system is a lot more forgiving
you can really just plop these things
down anywhere and they're very easy to
connect very easy to put down into all
kinds of shapes and especially the
highways although unfortunately I'm not
going to cover the highways in this
video yet
are also amazing the way that Lanes work
now is fantastic and a lot more user
friendly than in the first game so if
you haven't already I really recommend
checking out some content to see how the
road system has changed also to check
out the videos on the city skylines
channel on all the different parts of
this game because they go into a great
level of detail both with some cinematic
videos and some behind the scenes with
the the developers and it's really great
content so yeah I highly recommend it
anyway for this town I wanted to make
something kind of shaped like English
towns that you find all over the
countryside so to build this I spent a
lot of time on Google Maps because I'm
not very
experienced in making English towns and
something that I noticed well that's
very easy to notice straight away is
that the English Countryside has a very
particular look the fields aren't very
large they're not very straight either
they're just all these squiggly roads
everywhere and lots of Hedges and rows
of trees and bushes all around them so
it's a very interesting looking
Patchwork of small Fields with a lot of
foliage in between and something I
noticed is that a lot of the towns they
have these Victorian row houses and
semi-detached houses and also curvy
winding streets that also follow
typically the old rural landscape so
you'll have some fields that are very
curvy and then at some point in time
they started being filled in with these
houses somewhere during the 19th 20th
century and yeah you can really see that
the the cities kind of follow the rural
landscape in terms of their shape as
well which is very different from other
countries like say the Netherlands where
everything's a lot more planned out the
the fields are a lot more well larger in
general a bit more Square although that
also depends which parts of the
Netherlands you are but um yeah in
general it's very interesting to look at
I think it's also very different from
Belgium where everything's a lot more
just randomly dispersed because there
wasn't a lot of planning involved in
where the houses would go exactly and
you can definitely tell that in England
that's more of the case definitely
throughout the ages as well and it's
it's interesting in this way and this is
something that I really wanted to tackle
with this build it's interesting that
the way that cities grow is very
dependent on the networks of farm Fields
And Roads that have grown throughout
centuries at least if you look in
European countries and it really kind of
dictates that growth so very typically
you'll find that some of the main roads
in large cities were once the small
Roads connecting a very small town or
even Some Farms together and these
patterns end up you know changing over
the centuries but the basic layout is
still the same so ideally you want a
city to kind of grow alongside the
shapes of the rural landscape around it
and in City skylines you're often very
tempted to just start off with your city
as a blank slate and start building
whenever and for this build I thought it
would be interesting to try and use this
video to as much as possible work out
all of these Farm fields in this area
give this city a context in which it's
gonna grow and yeah become a realistic
organically grown City so I'm actually
going to spend most of my time in this
video laying out all of these paths and
Roads and farms and stuff like that and
trying to create a realistic ish English
rural landscape
and then at some later stage in time
we're gonna expand the city and see how
it's realistically gonna grow into this
landscape and yeah I think that's uh
something that I'm looking forward to a
lot now something that you might notice
already
is that the trees in this game are tiny
and this has been
on one hand is something that I really
like because it's realistic and
especially if you're making a new
neighborhood it's really cool that you
can tell that a neighborhood is new
because the trees are very young so
that's cool
but I'm trying my best here to create a
rural landscape that looks like it's
been here for ages and that creates a
perfect template for the city to grow
into and instead we have all of these
tiny little trees now there's another
challenge as well for this video I am
only allowed to go up to the Milestone
of ground Village and for some of the
later videos we're gonna go up to the
later Milestones now the idea behind
this is that over the next few weeks
you'll be able to see these cities that
all of your favorite creators are
building grow and and change over time
and you'll slowly see all of the
different features in the game and the
same goes for the creators as well which
is a really cool idea
but the way that you gain Milestones is
a little bit different from City
skylines one instead of being based just
on population it's based on XP and you
get XP from a bunch of things you
definitely get it for more population
but also a expanding other things about
your city expanding services or certain
buildings or your citizen happiness if
it increases you'll also get XP so I
think it's a more well holistic system
if you will it takes many things into
account which is very nice I think it's
uh it was a little bit too restrictive
to just be focused on population however
this also means that I have a deadline
for this video and not just in terms of
when I want to release it but also in
terms of when I have to stop playing and
um yeah it's as soon as I
and go beyond the current Milestone
which is ground Village I'm allowed to
still build while I'm in this Milestone
and use all of the stuff that you get
when you and when you get this Milestone
and part of that is of course expanding
the map size and part of that is
different Services now as you might also
notice but I'm going through this very
quickly but there's a system to the
things that you unlock with milestones
in City skylines one you would just
unlock typical Services anytime you get
to a given amount of population in this
case you're given points which you can
spend on any kind of development that
you want to so for instance
once you reach the first Milestone you
get a few points and you can spend those
points on unlocking roundabouts or you
can spend them on unlocking basic Road
services or maybe on something else so
you can choose what direction you want
to develop your your skill tree in in a
sense which is very nice because it
means that you're not just stuck with
whichever things the game decides you
unlock at a given Milestone
um so yeah that's quite nice but at the
same time I have to be very careful not
to reach the next Milestone and finish
this city as much as possible now as you
might notice my little thingy in the
bottom left corner which tells me how my
Milestone is doing and I'm currently on
level 4 the Grand Village so I'm no
longer allowed to reach any other
Milestone you can see the the bar is
kind of filling up a little bit and the
problem was as I discovered after a
little while that my citizens were very
happy and it was going well with my city
and I just kept getting XP even though I
wasn't really expanding
and this is a bit of an issue because
these trees take a pretty long time to
grow I wouldn't say quite a realistic
time and I'm very glad it's not a
realistic time in about a year or two
they'll typically grow to their full
size but a year takes long in this game
it'll take hours of play time for these
trees to all be grown and by that time
I'm definitely gonna have reached the
the next Milestone so if I want to work
out this rural landscape and make it
look like it's been here for a long time
and work it out as much as possible and
all of the foliage and stuff
that stuff is just not gonna work out so
I'm gonna have to come up with a
solution to prevent myself from reaching
the next milestone in order to show off
as much as possible as I can in this
video which it does sound a little bit
like cheating or at least it feels a
little bit like it but um I'm still
abiding by the rules technically
and yeah this is just something I really
really wanted to do for this video so
we're gonna have to come up with a
solution but for now I'm still working
on creating this rural urban fabric
which I'm trying to make it look as much
as possible like it's it's a very old
Patchwork of farm fields and
as much as I would have loved to use
Hedges here we're just sticking with
other parts of foliage some small paths
here and there and also some small roads
where we can also Place some houses here
and there and just make it make it look
like a very nice rural area
it's kind of fun to actually place all
of these trees down because it's
interesting to see that it doesn't quite
look the way that it's going to look
eventually while I'm working on this
because these trees get much much bigger
than your what you're looking at right
now these are basically just saplings
and especially some of the older trees
and the Oaks they're gonna grow so large
that you can barely see between them and
definitely some of the forests that I'm
gonna be making in this time are also
going to be very very dense that's
pretty cool and a lot of this work
honestly feels kind of like doodling I
find it very relaxing in a sense I think
the best way to make these organic
looking areas because I think it's
actually one of the hardest things to do
it's quite easy to lay down a grid and
make a very straightforward City but to
make something that looks like it didn't
have much thought in it put into it and
just kind of grew organically over time
it's quite difficult but I think the the
point to it is to try and follow the
terrain as much as possible there's a
slightly hilly terrain here and
sometimes it helps to come up with a way
that a road could have curved around
terrain and stuff like that it also
helps to turn off snapping for many of
these roads and paths I turned off
snapping which works very well in the
game actually and even without snapping
on you can connect different roads to
each other as long as you put them close
enough together and you get some nice
wobbly kind of roads which is exactly
what you're looking for and also I just
had Google Maps next to me the whole
time on another screen and just kept
moving around the English Countryside
looking at things and being like Oh yeah
I should just put a random Patchwork of
trees here and there
maybe we can have Little Valley you know
if there's a valley we can put a bunch
of trees in there and kind of make it
look like there's a little ditch and
stuff like that because realistically
these these these Farm Fields would have
grown organically over time also kind of
based on the low called geography and
once you've put in all of the trees
after you've already put in your most
basic roads and whenever you're placing
down your first route you should also
also make them look as quickly as
possible to already kind of shake
everything up and make sure you're not
gonna be staying too straight
um and after that you can just start
adding some houses and stuff like that
and eventually you end up with a
decently natural looking rural
environment I find
and yeah definitely don't be afraid to
put a lot of trees in the forests small
forests here and there in it as well
because looking at uh the English
Countryside You Know It This is Gonna
this is gonna sound so weird but it
almost kind of reminds me of a Picasso
painting with all of the the little
squares-ish looking shapes that aren't
exactly squares but just everything's a
little bit a little bit like cubism
almost just a little bit more organic
and full of Curves
uh also I decided to put some little
hamlets here and there so as you can
tell here I just added some houses there
and then over here we have this kind of
foresty area extending from the hamlets
which I think
it makes sense to break up the monotony
of the rural Fields otherwise and stuff
like that I think
um overall makes it look a bit more
natural over here we also have the
garbage facility which is quite cool you
can actually extend the uh the the area
that you dump the garbage so it's a
single building and then after that you
can make the garbage disposal side as
large as you want to
the same also goes for the Farms I put
down some Farms like a chicken farm over
there in the top left and it's cool that
you can just build The Farmhouse and
then afterwards you can create the shape
of the the farm field itself so that
also helps to make realistic looking
Farm areas because I wouldn't want
everything to just be green grass
realistically if you look at a rural
landscape there will be all kinds of
different crops and there will be some
fields that they're not using for a bit
so the soil can regain its strength I
guess that's a weird way to say it but
you know what I mean
um so you'll often have fields that look
all kinds of different colors so we want
to get a bit of that into it
realistically as well and then for some
of these roads in the town itself I'm
gonna be honest I actually worked out a
sketch for what I wanted the town to
look like and that's when I came up with
the one main road going through it and
another road splitting off at some point
going to the other side of the island
with the roundabout in it and then a lot
of the streets around this are kind of
shaped around that around the middle of
the roads we have some more straight
sections where we'll be able to have
lots of row houses and then toward the
edges of the town we'll have some some
bendy roads for the Bendy people with
lots of houses around them and kind of
moving into the fields and over here
we've got a more new ish area where it's
outside of the old town so we have space
to to build a roundabout realistically
that's the kind of things you see as
well and I think a good point of this
approach to building cities to try and
start off small and see how it would
have realistically grown over time is
that you also get touches like this you
know in the old parts of a city the
traffic situation is often pretty bad
because they just kind of organically
grew in times when cars didn't even
exist so you don't have a lot of space
to put roundabouts and stuff like that
and the infrastructure for cars that you
do have is kind of haphazardly but in
place after the facts whereas if you go
to newer parts of towns you'll have
separated roundabouts and maybe even
segregated bike lines and stuff like
that that was a weird way of saying bike
lane
um so you can start seeing these
differences as well so really you kind
of want your City to be banned in some
respects especially in around the city
center it's a kind of retroactively
start changing your city as well because
once you start changing and adding New
Roads into existing Town that's when it
starts looking a little bit more
realistic
and so for a lot of these roads as well
I tried to make them look like they're
just filling in Old Farm fields and
um yeah realistically I think this town
would have grown just alongside the two
main roads you know it would just be
some ribbon development alongside the
roads which is typically how most towns
in most European countries anyway start
off with and then somewhere during the
late 19th early 20th century it started
expanding beyond the ribbons of these
roads and started getting some actual
neighborhoods and yeah that's about that
also there's a bit of a Time skip you
might notice that we're already in
December
2013 and you might also notice that some
of the trees that I placed down first
are already growing quite a bit now the
trees in this game can grow up to 2 000
that's 2 000 wood that's their value in
terms of forest industry
and yeah it takes about two years to get
up to 2000 and I think the trees in the
middle right here now are somewhere
around a thousand so they're halfway
grown they're already looking pretty
nice but they're still gonna get a lot
bigger so that's something good to keep
in mind but once you see these trees
growing you can already see what this
area is supposed to kind of look like in
the near future with a few more farms
and some nice looking wheat Fields it's
starting to look more and more realistic
I think
also a good thing is we have a tree
brush in the game so for a lot of these
foresty areas I'm going with the tree
brush however the tree brush is not
super dense so personally I'd recommend
going for the tree brush and then adding
some individual trees in the middle of
the brushed areas so that's something
that I'm going for for a lot of these
spaces which is also pretty good because
it allows you to mix up different types
of trees together
something that I only noticed after this
build that I should have paid more
attention to is the fact that I placed
all of these rows of trees without
rotating the trees and it is something
that you're gonna notice in the end that
they do look very similar and in
hindsight I probably should have rotated
the trees but then again all of these
three lines are already individually
placed trees and the same goes for a lot
of the forests as well and if I started
rotating these things as well that would
have been a lot of work
um so yeah maybe for the three rows it's
good to rotate them but it's a lot of
effort for a small extra benefit so
minor notes for my future self but it's
not the biggest issue and maybe if I
hadn't pointed this out right now you
wouldn't even notice it but oh well
anyway over here we get another little
Hamlet
really make this look like we're in a
giant Patchwork of little towns and
farms on this island I'm also
considering that for some of the next
videos I might actually make some new
towns instead of expanding the town that
we have right now
um we'll see honestly I'm just gonna end
up doing what I feel like doing I'm not
even entirely sure what I'm gonna be
able to uh
unlock once I get to some of the new
updates so a lot of this stuff is still
a surprise for me as well I'm really
focusing on these trees and roads for
this episode but it's gonna look good in
the end I trust me now something that
I'm also very happy with is the fact
that the weather is very well suited for
my supposedly English town it's
constantly raining and you might see in
these time lapse videos that the the
lighting also changes throughout the
video due to the cloud coverage and rain
and stuff like that which is really cool
it really adds a sense of realism to the
game
anyway we now get to the end game of me
building this town and you very quickly
see me zoning everything because I
unzoned everything at some point and
turned off my
um powered generators which I guess in
this case are my wind turbines and my
sewage system to make sure everybody
left my city so I wouldn't be gaining
any more XP and I could actually work on
this town and let the trees grow without
having to finish this video but this had
a little bit of a downside as you can
see I'm very quickly expanding this town
and I'm very quickly gaining XP again
because it's it's expanding very rapidly
and also my my demand is kind of out of
whack which is a little bit of a shame
because altogether this means that I
won't be able to fully grow this town
into what it could be before the end of
this video because I'm gonna
I'm gonna reach the next Milestone
before I finish this so it's a little
bit unfortunate but on the other hand it
means that we have something to wait for
the next video for so a little bit of a
cliffhanger but I think it's fine and
it's just gonna make the next videos
that much better because I'll finally
get the opportunity to really work this
island into what I'm thinking of doing
with it but for now I had to add some
extra commercial and Industrial Zone
just to make sure that at least I got
some houses built on the main town so
that it could look decent for the final
video and also so that we can start
expanding this town in general so I
added this new Industrial Area here not
not exactly sure how well it's gonna
work out
um I do like that it definitely looks
like a much newer Industrial Area
compared to what we had and you can also
tell that by the infrastructure so I
think it's gonna work out fine
eventually we could maybe even add a
port in here at some point in the future
but yeah we'll just see what this grows
into organically over time anyway that's
it for the time lapse so let's quickly
check out the town and see how it's
doing
alright I wanted to look at what we have
right here but I just noticed that a
cloud is right on top of my town and now
it doesn't look the way I would like it
to
but you know that's the weather it's
actually kind of cool that this stuff
happens and that it actually affects the
lighting in the game as well so I'm
pretty happy with it overall also I just
noticed this thing is still turned off
anyway let's turn it on then there's our
landfill and here's everything else uh
my little town over here not entirely
sure what I'm going to call it yet but
it definitely deserves a name at some
point so does this one and so this the
big one I've opted for calling it Saint
Luke but I'm still not entirely sure if
I'm gonna stick with that it was kind of
a project name but honestly all things
considered it's good enough I think
and as you can see it still has some
filling in to do there's a lot of
residential areas that aren't filled in
by houses yet and yeah it just hasn't
reached its final form yet I think it's
gonna take the next video to actually
get there but eventually when all of
this is filled in with houses as well I
think we'll have a very nice transition
into the rural area here especially with
some houses alongside these bendy roads
so all things considered I'm very
hopeful for the future and I've had a
lot of fun doing this I honestly can't
wait to expand this town and especially
comparing vanilla City skylines due to
skylines one is a day and night
difference this is already a lot more
fun but also it's very doable to make
something that looks very realistic and
and one thing that also helps with that
for videos at least is this really cool
photo mode slash video mode that we now
have which allows us to do all kinds of
crazy things one of them is actually
change the weather change what our city
looks like we can add some new clouds
and stuff we can change the time of day
and actually create
some pretty cool looking uh sunsets as
well so yeah I'm very positive about my
gameplay so far honestly just can't wait
to play the game a little bit more and
also finish this town because there's
still a lot of work to be done but I
think it's going to be very doable for
the next video to finish this part of
the island and maybe this part of the
island as well because as our city gets
bigger we get more and more map tiles
unlocked and we'll be able to really
turn this into something and at some
point in the future we're probably gonna
cross over into the mainland start
building some highways and stuff like
that but for now this is going to be it
so I hope you guys enjoyed this look
into my first build in the game and yeah
let me know what you guys think of the
game from all of the videos that you've
seen so far and from this one as well
and I'll see you guys in the next one
thanks for watching ciao
foreign
[Music]